bonsoir et bienvenue à tous voici les
titres de l'actualité de ce mardi la
société générale en pleine tourmente les
appels à la démission de son pdg daniel
bouton se multiplient les rumeurs
d'offer assure la banque également le
gouvernement assure qu'il ne laissera
pas faire tout ça pour ça
le lundi de pentecôte reviendra un jour
férié dès cette année le principe d'une
journée de solidarité est maintenu mais
chaque entreprise en choisira la date
françois fillon promet 250 millions
d'euros de plus pour les sdf et le
logement d'urgence un document dans ce
journal
48 heures dans la peau d'un sans abri un
constat sans détour sur la réalité des
centres c'est le dossier de cette
édition
au kenya un premier dialogue entre la
présidence et l'opposition mais les
violences de plus en plus organisés ont
franchi un nouveau seuil en france des
stages de remise à niveau pour les
élèves de cm1 et de cm2 dès les vacances
de pâques une annonce du ministère de
l'éducation
stage qui seront assurés par des
enseignants volontaires enfin 160 étages
et plus de 800 mètres nous irons à la
découverte de la nouvelle tour la plus
haute du monde à dubaï la ville
chantilly on commence donc avec les
suites du scandale de la société
générale
aujourd'hui c'est sur la banque
elle-même que sont braqués les
projecteurs
son affaiblissement et l'effondrement de
son cours de bourse ces derniers jours
pourrait en faire une proie pour ses
concurrents par ailleurs de plus en plus
de voix s'élèvent je vous le disais pour
demander la démission du pdg daniel
bouton
sophie breuil zidène berkous
la fraude et la faute d'un seul homme
c'est la thèse défendue par daniel
bouton mais selon jérôme kerviel sa
hiérarchie était au courant
une défense qui fragilise un peu plus
encore le patron de la société générale
hier déjà nicolas sarkozy s'interroger
sur son maintien à la tête du groupe
certains représentants des salariés
envisagent eux aussi cette démission
mais pas tout de suite parce que donc
devrait rester au moins le temps de
boucler l'augmentation capital voire
aller jusqu'aux l'assemblée générale du
mois télé et la remet sa démission et on
discutera de son avenir et surtout au
delà du sort du président c'est l'avenir
de toute la banque qui pose problème
en plus de cette fraude record la
société générale évalue à 2 milliards
d'euros les pertes liées à la crise
américaine des subprimes
elle a aussi perdu la moitié de sa
valeur boursière en un an
de quoi relancer les rumeurs dopé assure
cette banque après une semaine de baisse
l'action à d'ailleurs clôturé en très
forte hausse aujourd'hui
le gouvernement affirme vouloir la
protéger la société générale c'est une
grande banque française et que le
gouvernement entend que la société
générale reste une grande banque
française
une volonté politique qui ne convainc
pas tous les actionnaires
la société générale est une société
privée ces actions sont en vente sur les
marchés
n'importe qui peut acheter des actions
de la société générale et si quelqu'un
veut faire une attaque je vois pas
comment on peut s'y opposer
la semaine dernière daniel bouton avait
proposé de démissionner demain matin le
conseil d'administration pourra à
nouveau examiné cette question et sept
associations de petits actionnaires
qu'on entendait à l'instant la dame va
également porter plainte pour délit
d'initié on a appris aujourd'hui que
robert day l'administrateur qui avait
vendu 85 millions d'euros d'actions le 9
janvier dernier en a également cédé pour
40 millions de plus neuf jours plus tard
alors que les soupçons de fraude était
déjà connue à la banque affirme
aujourd'hui que le conseil
d'administration en tout cas n'était pas
encore au courant
jérôme kerviel lui est évidemment
invisible mais la presse du monde entier
cherchent à le jouer
hier pour assurer une sortie discrète du
palais de justice
les policiers ont même eu recours à la
ruse l'homme caché dans cette voiture
est suivi par tous les journalistes
n'était qu'un leurre d'après son avocate
le trader se dit complètement écrasée
par la médiatisation de la faire
aujourd'hui on en sait un peu plus sur
son parcours
certains parlent de génie informatique
d'autres de personnes fragiles enquête
vincent fichman michel hiver cette image
a fait le tour du monde
elle provient du badge professionnel de
jérôme kerviel une simple photo
d'identité
pour en savoir un peu plus sur le
personnage il faut se tourner vers la
bretagne pont l'abbé ou l'enfance
heureuse d'un garçon discret et sportif
c'était quelqu'un de relativement
réservé bien sûr de relativement calme
posée sera mais par contre dès qu'il y
avait un coup de main à donner il était
toujours toujours partant le bac en
poche il se passionne pour la finance
pour cela il étudiera à lyon où il
obtiendra un dsr là-bas peu de souvenirs
de l'élève kerviel a par son habituelle
discrétion
j'étais un bon étudiant japonais julien
exceptionnellement fin à un système
magnifique avec une mention assez bien
à la sortie de l'école il débute
modestement à la société générale dans
un bureau de contrôle
quatre années après à force de travail
il endosse le costume du parfait golden
boy celui dont il a toujours rêvé
lille devient trader lors de sa garde à
vue comme le révèle lemonde.fr
il déclare j'ai été bien moins
considérer que les autres ont regardé
mon cursus universitaire et de mon
parcours professionnel et personnel
le monde des traders une sorte
d'aristocratie de la finance ou sur les
écrans les chiffres se lisant millions
généralement un trader lorsqu'elle gagne
de l'argent devient le foriic se croit
quelques par le maître du monde il se
croit presque invincible et peu dans
cette situation se mettre à prendre des
risques élevés
ce pourrait être le cas pour jérôme
kerviel mais autour de lui personne ne
veut le voir comme un fraudeur il a été
manoeuvre et c'est pas possible qu'il
ait pu faire de lui-même une chose
pareille et c'est un garçon sérieux
honnête très famille réserver ses
collègues parlent d'un homme discret
voire secret en tout cas pas le profil
pour devenir le plus célèbre trader du
moment cette affaire de la société
générale ne doit pas masquer les
conséquences de la crise financière qui
a secoué les places boursières du monde
entier il ya quelques jours
cette fois c'est une certitude elle ne
sera pas sans conséquences sur
l'économie réelle le fmi le fonds
monétaire international affiche
aujourd'hui son pessimisme
et c'est dans ce contexte que se réunit
ce soir à londres un mini sommets
européens france allemagne grande
bretagne italie pour réfléchir à une
parade et peut-être à de nouvelles
règles
françois beaudonnet géraldine en choses
sur place
ils sont venus au chevet d'un système
financier malade
les dirigeants de quatre grands pays
européens et le président de la
commission sont réunis depuis une heure
au 10 downing street
les chefs d'état et de gouvernements
tentent de répondre à une question
cruciale comment éviter l'implosion de
la planète financière
mais huit jours seulement après le lundi
noir en europe ils ne sont pas d'accord
sur les remèdes
nicolas sarkozy et romano prodi veulent
obliger les banques et les marchés
financiers à plus de transparence en
gala merkel et gordon brown au contraire
ne veulent pas d'une régulation
contraignante
bref en langage diplomatique on dit ici
que les discussions seront franche et
pendant que l'europe discute le fonds
monétaire international lui vient
d'abaisser ses prévisions de croissance
mondiale
avant même d'être achevée cette réunion
a montré qu'en matière financière
les européens ne sont pas unis la
présidence de l'union européenne
en effet regretté que cette réunion ait
lieu à quatre et non pas à 27 ce thème
de la crise a aussi dominé la nuit
dernière l'ultime discours sur l'état de
l'union de george bush devant les
parlementaires il a concédé que
l'économie américaine entrée joli site
dans une période d'incertitude tout en
se montrant confiant et en confirmant
son choix d'une baisse d'impôts pour
relancer la croissance en france
un petit tour et puis s'en va le lundi
de pentecôte redeviendra finalement un
jour férié dès cette année ce sera le 12
mai en revanche l'idée d'une journée de
solidarité n'est pas abandonné mais ce
sera à la carte entreprise par
entreprise
fabien shadow eric de l'agneau
c'est la fin d'un long feuilleton la
france coupée en deux à chaque lundi de
pentecôte de le printemps prochain
cette journée redeviendra un jour férié
objectif ne pas revivre le grand bazar
des années passées une journée noire
pour la moitié des salariés qui sont
allés travailler
que faire par exemple des enfants privés
d'école vous avez des cas de figure dans
certains établissements ou si la crèche
et fermer l'entreprise
elle va travailler donc les parents de
veiller travailler et ce jour là ils ont
pas de vote de gains le lundi de
pentecôte travaillé avait été mise en
place après la canicule de 2003 par le
gouvernement raffarin pour financer la
solidarité envers les personnes âgées
tiens à dire combien je compte sur ce
surcroît de fraternité dans la société
française par cette journée de la
solidarité et de la fraternité
pour faire face à ce défi du
vieillissement face à la difficile mise
en oeuvre de cette mesure le
gouvernement a décidé de simplifier le
fonctionnement de cette journée de
solidarité
je suis pragmatique j'ai pris un
calendrier le jeudi oui mais le vendredi
le samedi 10 jusqu'au lundi 12 c'est pas
un bon c'est un viaduc
on va dire les choses comme ça donc on
aurait été incapable d'organiser les
choses intelligemment pour financer la
journée de solidarité
les salariés auront désormais le choix
ils pourront donner deux demi journées
de congé ou de rtt ou bien versé 7
heures de travail à n'importe quel
moment de l'année 2008 sera donc un bon
cru
on pose en un jour au mois de mai les
français auront droit à cinq jours de
repos
le gouvernement l'avait promis françois
fillon a annoncé aujourd'hui des mesures
pour les sans abri et le logement
d'urgence une enveloppe de 250 millions
d'euros sera débloqué cette année un
super préfet entre guillemets sera
chargé de coordonner l'action sur le
terrain et un plan pluriannuel
ambitionne de résorber l'habitat
insalubre d'ici quatre ans les
associations sont très déçus pour elle
ces moyens sont insuffisants image
signée josée boulesteix alors cette
controverse n'est pas nouvelle pour
mieux approcher la réalité l'accueil
d'urgence nous avons eu recours à une
méthode inhabituel l'un de nos reporters
s'est mis pendant deux jours dans la
peau d'un sans abri à la
cherche d'un centre c'est le récit de
cette expérience que nous vous proposons
ce soir une réalité vous allez le voir
sans fard parfois dur
voici ce document c'est le dossier de
cette édition il est signé et loire
berges ans et mathias barrois mon but ce
soir c'est de dormir au chaud car dans
la rue il fait 5 degrés je marche sans
trop savoir où aller vers 19 heures
j'appelle le 115 le 115 c'est
l'hébergement d'urgence des sdf 30
minutes d'attentes un serveur vocal
traduit en arabe et en roumain me fait
patienter réponse au bout d'une heure
après une liste de questions vous avez
pas du plus du tout de place
mais comment on fait alors
d'argent pas de place pas de mesures
exceptionnelles car il ne fait pas assez
froid on m'indique alors un point de
rendez-vous au nord de paris
normalement là bas pas besoin de
réservations un bus fait la navette vers
un centre d'hébergement au moins 200
candidats majoritairement afghans
iraniens et africains mais surprise
seuls les inscrits sur une liste peuvent
remonter pour le troisième non je ne
sais toujours pas où dormir
on m'a parlé d'un petit centre d'accueil
vers la gare de lyon alors une nouvelle
fois je traverse paris car être sdf fait
marcher des kilomètres chaque jour pour
se déplacer et ne pas avoir froid ses
rondeurs et la place 3d de la place
s'est pas ouverte
mouvement ses meubles s'est pas ouvert
c'est sûr qu'à leur place mais il faut
réserver
non c'est les premiers vous ici pas dit
pas de douche que du carrelage des
chaises qui donne des courbatures et une
soupe chaude 50 sans abri s'entassent
lever 5 heures du matin des conditions
très rudes ya de gens connaissent très
bien
3e canton cherche à dormir aussi pendre
le matin si vous y prenez à la dernière
minute ce soir c'est complet parcours
1915 sont les a appelés il était dans à
8 heures les listes sont faites à partir
de midi à midi ce qui m'a plu fort de ce
conseil je reste dormir à l'abri sur ma
chaise j'appellerai le 115 demain matin
pour m'assurer d'un vrai lit le
lendemain soir inscrit nous sommes 45
entassés derrière cette cloison
majoritairement des étrangers en france
un sdf sur cinq est sans papiers nous
roulons sans bruit vers la boulangerie
un gros centre d'hébergement au nord de
paris
toute la soirée les bus affrétés par la
ratp déposent leur lot de sans abri
300 chacun a le droit à un kit de
toilette une couverture et une serviette
on peut même déposé ses objets de valeur
dans un casier sécurisé selon concret
n'est pas de chambres séparées mais un
immense dortoir 286 lie tous occupés le
centre est saturé tous les soirs et
pourtant c'est étrangement calme mon lit
pour cette nuit et ici au fond d'eux
s'est rangé il baigne dans une flaque
d'eau un lit et microbes en plus de la
promiscuité
l'odeur est là aussi insupportable c'est
encore pire dans les algeco fait
aménager en bloc sanitaire à côté une
salle de prière improvisé en face des
polonais se couvre les cheveux
moi je me brosse les dents avec la
nausée
la première nuit ici j'arrive pas à
dormir je ne sais pas facilement 23h
extinction des feux
le chauffage ronfle aussi fort que les
hommes mon voisin lui est en détresse
6 heures du matin comme tous ici je me
réveille fatigué lumière aveuglante set
efficace pour un levée rapide j'ai du
mal à rentrer dans les sanitaires faire
ma toilette le ménage n'a pas été fait
trois mois
celui-ci tu vas
et suivant
pour voter il est
dans un temps
avoir publié les
une fois le petit déjeuner avalé retour
à la rue la priorité de ce sdf rappelé
le 115
avant d'aller travailler pour la plupart
d'entre eux ils sont intérimaires
ouvriers certains ont même un cdi
presque comme monsieur tout le monde
voilà pour cette enquête alors nous
avons souhaité cet après-midi faire
réagir la ministre du logement christine
boutin à ces images voici son
commentaire
je suis à la tristesse de vous dire que
c'est effectivement la vie des personnes
qui sont sans domicile fixe et que c'est
naturellement une vie très très dur
alors
il est bien évident qu'on ne peut pas
s'en satisfaire et comme vous l'avez dit
il via des personnes désocialisées
mais il ya aussi des travailleurs
pauvres qui est parce qu il ya eu une
rupture familiale parce qu'il y avait un
problème de santé parce que il y a eu un
problème de professionnels se retrouvent
à la rue
notre volonté est au gouvernement il ya
moi aussi bien sûr c'est de répondre à
cette tragédie
et tout cela est dû au fait qu'en france
il n'y a pas suffisamment de logements
propos recueillis par mathias second
l'éducation depuis quelques années les
stages de remise à niveau des élèves
sont devenus monnaie courante pour les
familles aisées
ils sont assurés par des organismes
privés et bien le gouvernement souhaite
les proposer à tous les enfants en
difficulté dès les prochaines vacances
de pâques
ils seront assurés par des enseignants
volontaires payés en heures
supplémentaires
c'est en tout cas l'idée du ministère de
l'éducation pour l'instant seuls les
élèves de cm1 et de cm2 sont concernés
nabila taboury paris crocs adieu les
matchs de foot
les balades à vélo et la console de jeux
les vacances de pâques
ça risque bientôt de ressembler à ça des
stages de remise à niveau
l'idée vient du ministre de l'éducation
depuis des années 15% des élèves qui
arrivent en sixième ne savent ni lire ni
compter
au collège il est déjà trop tard les
élèves concernés ce2 cm1 et de cm2
l'expérimentation commencera aux
vacances de pâques et sera renouvelé
l'été prochain trois heures de révisions
par jour pendant une semaine
au programme du français et des
mathématiques les élèves seront
volontaires tout comme les professeurs
qui les encadreront les enseignants
seront payés en heures supplémentaires
c'est presque par dans sept écoles zep
de la banlieue parisienne le soutien
scolaire les élèves en bénéficient déjà
tous les soirs de la semaine
l'idée d'en faire même pendant les
vacances ça ne ravit pas l'institutrice
si en plus on empiète sur leurs vacances
pour travailler encore en plus ça fait
beaucoup
et puis comment leur faire comprendre
que voilà eux doivent venir alors que
d'autres ne viennent pas c'est sa
s'édifie son de cloche différent chez
les élèves et leurs parents
beaucoup n'ont pas les moyens de partir
en vacances l'école c'est parfois mieux
que rien moi ça me dérangerait pas vu
que je travaille pas et que l'option
part pas en vacances et puis je trouve
ça bien pour les enfants entre 5 cm dans
cus jahiz apprennent à l'école mme avec
les vacances il est damphousse
si l'expérience est concluante ces
stages seront proposées partout en
france pour les mêmes périodes de pâques
et des vacances d'été
en bref les obsèques des trois gendarmes
tués vendredi dernier lors d'une course
poursuite à neuf châteaux il avait été
percuté par un train beaucoup d'émotion
pendant la cérémonie à laquelle
assistaient nicolas sarkozy il a
réaffirmé sa volonté de punir les
multirécidivistes en référence à l'homme
qui est à l'origine de l'accident et qui
est également décédé imaginiez
jean-pierre pasteur à l'étranger le
double visage du kenya le parallèle est
saisissant
d'un côté l'espoir avec ces premières
discussions entre le président kibaki et
son principal opposant odinga elles se
sont déroulées en présence du médiateur
kofi annan et la cérémonie était
retransmise en direct à la télévision
et puis de l'autre causé le vent de
folie qui continue à s'étendre
les violences ont franchi ces dernières
heures un nouveau seuil elles sont de
moins en moins spontané de plus en plus
organisée le cycle de la vengeance
semble enclenché attention si des
enfants sont à vos côtés
certaines images peuvent choquer claude
sans père
le kényan au bord de la guerre civile
aujourd'hui la situation semble échapper
à tout contrôle dans de nombreuses
villes du pays
les affrontements interethniques font
chaque jour de plus en plus de victimes
ce matin à névache à une ville à 40 km
au nord ouest de nairobi
la police a dû tirer depuis des
hélicoptères pour disperser la foule au
sol le face à face a duré des heures
d'un côté les partisans du président
kibaki
membre de l'ethnie kikuyu et de l'autre
les supporters de l'opposition membres
de l'ethnie lui au au milieu quelques
policiers impuissants
le kenyan qui sombre aujourd'hui dans la
violence était jusque là un des pays les
plus calmes d'afrique de l'est
ancienne colonie britannique depuis
l'indépendance en 1963
le pays vivait en paix avec ses 50 et ni
des ti majoritaire les kikuyu détient
les rênes du pouvoir et de l'économie
l'élu aux principales ethnies de
l'opposition réclame aujourd'hui un
partage des richesses le président
kibaki est kikuyu mais son opposant
raila odinga élus haut jusqu'à présent
les différents groupes ethniques
vivaient les uns à côté des autres
aujourd'hui les pillages les moeurs mais
violent les règlements de comptes se
succèdent la presse et l'armée agissent
avec beaucoup de brutalité et personne
ne sait ce soir comment arrêter
s'étendre mange de la violence
en somalie trois employés de médecins
sans frontières dont un français un
logisticien damien le hâle ont été tuées
dans un attentat ainsi qu'un journaliste
là bas les attaques des insurgés
islamistes sont quasi-quotidiennes
attentat également en algérie une
voiture piégée visant un commissariat à
50 km à l'est d'alger a explosé tuant au
moins quatre personnes ce matin dont
trois policiers et le kamikaze
pas de revendication pour l'instant aux
etats unis une étape importante dans la
course à la maison blanche côté
républicain on vote aujourd'hui en
floride et l'ancien maire de new york
rudolph giuliani donné favori il ya
quelques mois encore a tout misé sur cet
état mais les sondages sont pessimistes
pour lui s'il est battu
il lui sera bien difficile de revenir
sur les deux favoris john mccain est
mitt romney sur place en floride envoyés
spéciaux alain de chalvron aaron diamond
et voici le prochain président des états
unis
rudi giuliani c'est quitte ou double
pour rudi giuliani
ça passe ou ça casse l'ancien maire de
new york a tout misé sur la floride et
fait l'impasse sur les primaires
précédente
il va gagner et ce sera grâce à vous il
est bien optimiste l'ancien favori des
sondages il est maintenant à la traîne
et à ses meetings il y a moins de
supporters que de journalistes venus
assister à cette déconfiture annoncée
oui c'est sûr il aura besoin de leur
aide à tous ces retraités venus
rechercher en floride un petit coin de
paradis ensoleillé
ils viennent souvent de new york et
garde pour l'homme du 11 septembre
une certaine tendresse
je ne pense pas qu'il est une chance de
gagner ça ne m'empêchera tout de même
pas de voter pour lui
autre fief supposée du candidat little
havana la petite havane la communauté
cubaine qui aurait été séduite par le
discours résolument anti castristes de
julia ni mais voilà entre deux parties
de dominos les cubains de miami en
regarder les sondages et changer de
champion giuliani a été un bon maire
pour new york
il a mis du maroc par tous fait une
belle ville mais mccain lui a été
prisonnier derrière
il sait ce que c'est les communistes et
vous n'aimez pas les communistes ça
c'est sûr cloud résultats dans les
sondages julian y est 3e voire même
quatrième loin derrière mccain et romney
qui eux sont au coude à coude résultats
donc cette nuit direction dubaï et
maintenant la course au gigantisme est
relancée depuis quelques années par les
nouveaux dragons asiatiques et les
émirats arabes et bien la ville dubaï
détient le nouveau record du gratte ciel
le plus haut du monde
plus de 800 mètres de haut 160 étages le
chantier touche à sa fin samah soula
francis bianconi
au pays de l'or noir il est d'usagé de
parler avec des superlatifs
voici donc burj dubaï la plus haute tour
du monde
817 mètres de haut un sommet visible 95
km à la ronde
ce sera la plus luxueuse la plus chère
son ascenseur le plus au monde
il grimpera 162 étages suspendues à des
centaines de mètres d'altitude
les ouvriers n'ont mis que cinq ans à
réaliser l'ouvragé en travaillant jour
et une heure on a poussé à l'extrême
continue de réaliser aujourd'hui en
terme de technique de pompage
d'adduction d'eau et d'installations
d'ascenseur ce sont les éléments les
plus sophistiquées que l'on pourra
trouver dans le monde avec 6 817 mètres
burj dubai dépassera de loin les autres
tours actuellement en construction
notamment celle qui va remplacer les
tours jumelles à new york qui fera
seulement 541 être balayés donc les
vieux records
loin derrière nos modestes tour eiffel
et tour montparnasse board dubaï sera en
fait une véritable ville dans la ville
avec appartements bureaux boutiques
piscine jardin suspendu et hôtel de très
grand luxe
la tour est toujours en travaux mais le
groupe accor il ya déjà ouvert son hôtel
haut de gamme
le site serait idéal nous sommes à deux
pas de la bourse de dubaï et également à
trois minutes du plus grand shopping du
monde donc en fait ce que nous espérons
attirer ce jugement cette clientèle qui
vient dubaï pour les affaires et pour le
loisir luxe et prestige
la stratégie du petit émirat qui ni sur
le tourisme le secteur représente 33 %
de ses revenus contre seulement trois
pour cent pour le pétrole
une visite de bill gates en france
réception à l'elysée à la mairie de
paris
mais aussi discours devant les étudiants
de la sorbonne et échanges également
medef avec laurence parisot pour le
cofondateur de microsoft qui est
maintenant engagé vous le savez à 100%
dans sa fondation
si bill gates est le patron le plus
emblématique des états unis ratan tata
est le plus connu en inde et dans une
grande partie de l'asie
la basse est une dynastie depuis près de
deux siècles c'est aussi un groupe
omniprésent dans l'acier la banque ou
l'alimentaire aux manches tata on
dépense tata ont vite atteint reportage
arnauld miguet fabrice launay sous
l'objectif des photographes du monde
entier le pdg de tata des voilettes il y
a quelques semaines la voiture à 1700
euros moins chère du monde
une petite révolution une révolution
thatta nous ne voulons pas devenir une
entreprise mondiale comme coca cola tel
n'est pas notre attention
nous voulons juste nous développer à
l'international sur des marchés
spécifiques un message clair ce groupe
100% indien a bien l'intention de sortir
de ses frontières en inde impossible d'y
échapper celtes et automobile
électricité banque assurance téléphone
d'ataï partout sans oublier l'acier
et c'est là que tout a commencé job chez
pour à l'est du pays et son navire
amiral la plus ancienne aujourd'hui la
plus importante à siri le fondateur du
groupe nationaliste et visionnaire
voulait une inde indépendante de l'
empire britannique
il décida il ya un siècle de fonder un
empire industriel de temps kevin comme
ça à l'époque on parlait d' indépendance
politique
j'aime cette fatale lui parler
d'indépendance économique economic and
dependence jam jet pour ville de jam
chef d'ata elle porte son nom et sa
marque il d'avant-garde créé pour les
ouvriers avec ses espaces verts ses
écoles et son hôpital date a fait du
social avant leur journée de huit heures
congés payés dès 1920 16 ans avant la
france
jeannard dan band est comme beaucoup
d'indiens rêvait il y à 32 ans de
travailler chez tata comme les
vingt-huit mille salariés de l'usiné il
a droit à un logement qu'ils payent huit
petits euros par mois cet appartement
dans lequel vit toute sa famille
il gagne 400 euros par mois les études
de ses cinq enfants tu été prise en
charge par l'entreprise
ici c'est une ville propre
on ne se croirait pas en inde on a l'eau
potable gratuite l'électricité des
commerces ouverts 24 heures sur 24
c'était le diable de vivre dans cet
endroit
sata l'icône nationale emploie 250 mille
personnes et produit à elle seule en
inde 3 % de la richesse nations encore
peu connu en france même si nous
consommons du tata sont souvent le
savoir sous forme de thé ou d'acier ya
fort à parier que cet empire indien se
fera dans les prochaines années un nom
en europe et dans l'hexagone alerte au
cyclone à la réunion l'ouragan goula
pour est passé tout près de lille dans
la journée d'après demain si vous êtes
sur place vous êtes invités à faire des
réserves d'eau et à sortir le moins
possible
l'espace avec le problème de plus en
plus épineux des débris spatiaux
notamment les vieux satellite qui ne
fonctionne plus mais qui tourne toujours
autour de la terre les risques
d'accident sont réels le cnes le centre
national d'études spatiales souhaite
généraliser une technique qui existe
déjà
celle du cimetière spatiale explications
patrice pelé josé boulesteix après le
décollage
la fusée libère sa coiffe dans l'espace
un exemple de débris spatial depuis le
sol
on les traque ces débris et la
comptabilité est alarmante
en 40 ans plus de deux cent mille objets
ont été abandonnées les plus dangereux
sont les satellites mort à trente six
mille kilomètres impossible de les faire
revenir faire la terre pour qu'ils
brûlent pour cela le cnes a trouvé la
solution un cimetière dans l'espace
pour l'ancien cimetière et on a mis tous
les satellites a dit on va les mettre
dans ce cimetière et ils resteront comme
les morts au cimetière jusqu'à ce que
jusqu'à la scène du temps la technique
va consister à remonter de 300 km les
satellites vers l'orbité cimetière et
pour éviter la prolifération des débris
la france travaille aussi sur une
réglementation internationale
objectif imposer aux opérateurs de
l'espace des règles anti pollution un
espace propre
bientôt la station spatiale et les
satellites pourront tourner en toute
tranquillité retour sur la terre ferme
avec un triste palmarès publié chaque
année celui des voitures les plus volées
en france il faut savoir qu'on cote
qu'on compte 390 vols par jour
résultat de cette enquête de nos
confrères d'auto plus les petites
citadines sont plus prisées que les
grosses berlines
voici pourquoi françois jullien
pieds-noirs jean francois monier
c'est la plus petite voiture du moment
et c'est aussi la voiture la plus volée
en france la smart
c'est le résultat d'une enquête du
magazine auto plus en 2007 143 milles
130 véhicules ont été volés soit 390 par
jour derrière la smart coup de coeur des
voleurs la renault twingo et la peugeot
306 trois citadines convoité pour leur
vulnérabilité
souvent pas d'alarmé pas de système
antidémarrage pour les plus anciennes
c'est marginal quand elles sont revendus
entière en fait vraiment leur usage
principal c'est de servir de banque de
pièces détachées pour pour répondre à la
demande qui existe parce qu'encore une
fois ce sont des véhicules de très
grande diffusion et pour ouvrir ces
petites voitures regarder la méthode
traditionnelle un simple tournevis dans
la serrure tellement facile que les
propriétaires de smart le reconnaît
semaines qu'on peut l'ouvrir au moins
quatre
c'est à l'intérieur oui et bien portants
tout cas pas contents et vous ne savez
pas comment mais quand vous êtes j'ai
essayé mais puisqu'on se retrouve
souvent les clés et fermez votre victime
de son succès la smart passe de la
troisième place en 2006 à la première
aujourd'hui et les grosses berlines
elles apparaissent plus bas dans le
palmarès car mieux protégés mais que
feront tourner les alarmes la méthode
peut être plus violente
c'est ce qu'on appelle le car jacking un
feutre à 7800 euros une robe d'avocat à
8000 euros c'est un peu de françois
mitterrand qui était vendue aux enchères
cet après midi à drouot sa garde-robe
était mise à prix pour financer
l'association de danielle mitterrand
france libertés et les nuques virginie
travers le feutre noir de chez arnys
l'emblématique chapeau de françois
mitterrand adjugé 100 fois son prix 18
ans c'est bien vu 7800 euros l'acheteur
le parti socialiste les symboles reste
dans la famille mais votre objet très
peu trop mal tout entre les mains d'un
adversaire jean montaldo hauteur de
pamphlet virulent sur l'ancien président
achète ses pantoufles et dérobaient
floride robot joindre à moi j'aimais
boonen oui je suis gentil et sharp
costumes en casquette s'arrache d'eau
plus fort chacun a une bonne raison
un peu de lui quoi et
en imaginant qu'ils les aient porté ce
qui peut forcément le cas chez intel
temps record pour la robe d'avocat de
françois mitterrand a jugé 8000 euros à
un membre du barreau
la vente devrait rapporter entre 60 et
90 mille euros à la fondation france
libertés de danielle mitterrand du
cinéma avec la sortie d'un film anglais
qui provoque un choc aux états unis
la bataille de radis tas il est inspiré
d'un fait réel le massacre en irak de 24
civils par des marines américains après
la mort d'un des leurs bruno le dreff
patrice brugère le 24 novembre 2005 dans
la ville d'haditha en irak
une bombe explose au passage d'un convoi
américain et fait un mort les marines
solange ils abattent 24 civils irakiens
se fait réel rapidement dénoncé comme
crimes de guerre est l'objet du film de
nick broomfield tourné comme un
reportage l'histoire est racontée à
travers la journée des poseurs de bombes
de civils irakiens et d'un groupe de
soldats
un souci de réalisme que le réalisateur
a poussé loin
les deux principaux acteurs sont
d'anciens marines qui ont servi en irak
engagé à 17 ans elliot ruiz a été
grièvement blessé lors de l'insurrection
de tikrit tu eric mais halak au boulot
ce n'est au québec a fait deux séjours
de longue durée en irak
on savait qu'à main par les ans ça va
quand même être l'uniforme on savait
comment insérer les tactiques beaucoup
de ça a mené les faits j'avais
l'impression d'être à nouveau sur le
terrain
la seule différence c'est qu'à la fin de
la journée le réalisateur disait coupée
aucun film anti guerre la bataille du
tas n'est pas pour autant un film anti
américain
vous savez s'entraîne dur pour apprendre
la discipline
malheureusement ce jour là a dit tard
les gars ont paniqué ils ont laissé
leurs émotions déborder leur sens de la
discipline
c'est terrible quand des choses comme ça
arrivent car tout est alors amplifié une
fiction dans laquelle il n'y a ni bon ni
mauvais mais où il ne reste que des
victimes
et puis on a appris dans l'après-midi la
mort du comédien philippe khorsand
figure populaire de la télévision il
avait été révélé par la série palace
il était aussi très en vue ces derniers
mois avec son personnage dans une
publicité satirique pour un groupe
d'assurances il avait 59 ans les sports
en bref avec le retour du héros jo
wilfried tsonga est arrivé ce matin à
l'aéroport de roissy charles de gaulle
accueilli par ses proches et surtout de
très nombreux journalistes
il fait un bond à la 18e place mondiale
à l'atp et fait aussi sa sélection en
équipe de france de coupe davis face à
la roumanie
il m'a signé vincent barral et puis du
football avec comme chaque jour la coupe
d'afrique des nations la côte d'ivoire
élimine le mali en 3 0 on en parlait
hier de la côte d'ivoire du signé drogba
zorro et sanogo
le nigeria s'est également qualifié pour
les quarts de finale en s'imposant face
au bénin 2-0 côte d'ivoire vivait ce
sera le premier de ces quarts le 3
février avant de refermer ce journal je
vous en rappelle l'un des principaux
titres la société générale en pleine
tourmente les appels à la démission de
son pdg daniel bouton se multiplient les
rumeurs dopé assure la banque également
le gouvernement assure qu'il fera tout
pour que la société générale reste une
banque française
c'est la fin de ce journal merci de
l'avoir suivi tout de suite la météo
laurent romejko 20h50 un téléfilm de
prestige de nina companeez voici venir
l'orage c'est le premier volet avec
notamment natacha régnier à demain
l'info en continu cétacés sur france 2
point fr